[Music]
the only thing separating him from a 100
person fight to the death is one dive a
handful of seconds to contemplate his
landing what his first step will be and
how he'll fend off his foes he's been
here before he's the king around this
island boots touch snow and he's home a
K in hand
my peen duck oh yeah you can suck it up
you're insane oh my god this is the
story of fortnight's greatest
[Applause]
[Music]
the story of T Fuu Turner T Foote any
story doesn't start in front of a
computer screen it doesn't even start
with a controller in his hands or on the
stage of a major eSports event
he wasn't even allowed to play video
games growing up well we never played
video games at all growing up I think
the first time he ever played a video
game he was like 12 or 13 his story
starts in his own backyard on a
trampoline with his brothers next to the
ocean
Shifu and his brother Jack grew up right
next to the beach in Florida hi my two
brothers my sister we're all
homeschooled our entire lives our
parents didn't believe this school
system would be good for us and they
thought that they could just teach us on
their own better than what we would
learn in school and as you can imagine
this resulted in a pretty unique
relationship between four siblings who
spent every day together he and his
brother began to film virtually
everything they did according to Jack
the remainder of their adolescence
spiraled into a whirlwind of cameras
gags and all the by the ocean activities
that sell vacation packages T foo bounce
from balancing runescape with competing
in skimboarding competitions all over
the US to a competitive long boarding
phase in 2012 and then an obsession that
he appears to have never kicked flip
Turner started busting out double flip
landing the perfectly first try and
around that time and really started
stepping it up and hitting big bridge
dumps and doing backflips upwards of 85
feet so how did this Lords of Dogtown
ask lifestyle land tifu in front of a
computer screen well like a lot of the
gaming world that metamorphosis happened
because of the youtube Jack had been
uploading skim and surf content to his
own YouTube channel now known as jig
squad and in the early days T foo was
featured on the channel styling and
whatever board sport they were obsessed
with at the time in addition to their
escapades in sports the channel grew to
be filled with various pranks and fails
videos in particular they spent a lot of
time messing with unassuming beachgoers
[Laughter]
[Music]
as early as 2013 when Jack was 19 and T
foo was 16 the channel had more than
10,000 subscribers this is a stick up
and it was then amidst this homeschooled
rambunctious prank filled videotape
everything environment the teeth who
decided to start his own YouTube channel
in 2015 that focused on gaming so yeah I
was gaming you know also helping him on
the side but focusing more on like
gaming and streaming yet another world
where he was a level above his peers
defendant Odin his YouTube channel
started where many great gaming channels
have with call of duty
specifically he would upload advanced
warfare highlights
before anybody knew chief whose name his
proficiency with a scoped rifle was
undeniable it was destiny that became a
fixture of chief whose early YouTube
content as his channel became more
consistent
once I started get really good at
destiny and I got partnered on twitch
and started making like a little bit of
money off of like YouTube like
speedrunning and doing whatever that's
when I really realized that like this is
a you know but to start his YouTube
channel was just that your
run-of-the-mill gaming channel but damn
was he good
he's dead
whoo oh my lord
that said as time went on that beach bum
jig squad content started to creep into
his channel in small doses a few moments
later breathe to one as you do when
you're a teenager uploading content
doing stupid [ __ ] and hoping something
sticks T Fuu was experimenting even then
the ever calm temperament that he's
become synonymous with was fully present
[Music]
since h1z1 crept into the forefront if
the gaming is at Geist in 2017 you
haven't been able to open twitch or
click into YouTube without being smacked
in the face with a fight to the death oh
my god
and would be our blew up tea booze
content centered around the most
streamable gaming archetype the world
had ever seen a trajectory that led him
head-to-head with a familiar foe I'm a
ninja I've been playing verse each other
for years now me and him used to play
verse each other in each one of a nerdy
play mmm battle royale provides an
almost locker-room feel to the streamer
and viewer experience it's not all
encompassing like League of Legends game
play or overwatch and feels as if it's
designed to let streamers showcase their
personality while engaging their
audience
I gotta kill this I had dr. h1z1 set the
mold table she changed the game
yesterday [ __ ] that h1z1 and pub jhiera
during 2017 was good to tee foo he made
a name for himself through his all
inspiring aim and was a force to be
reckoned with in any shooter this homie
Cruz on the [ __ ] ATV right now
right if you like I just got [ __ ]
dome-piece by the Magnum in one of their
helmets like really fun party yep get a
[ __ ] gun ski dude good [ __ ] did I had
14 kills how many have uh 20 as if New
Year's Day 2018 he was sitting at just
over 65 thousand subs on YouTube and was
streaming to just a couple of hundred
viewers at a time on Twitch chief who
was cementing himself as one of the best
battle royale players on the planet we
did it boys we dropped a 30 bomb in pub
and that process was accelerated when
the game changed again but I don't think
it was really until like four net came
out with stuff really started to like
start blowing up late in 2017
fortnight's battle royale mode launched
its assault on the gaming streaming
sometimes dancing and all-around
pop-culture world it connects to many
many people around the world you can buy
these dan's emotes that basically are
trending nowadays it enchanted the minds
of everyone whether you were a gamer a
personality or a celebrity fortnight was
everywhere and cemented itself as the
battle royale title to play hi just go
let's go oh I didn't even heal in a row
right those shitness isn't this might
kill you I'm giving doors I'm giving you
doors
oh my god I said did you did and in a
throwback to his days at the beach
Shifu caught this wave and held it the
result was his gameplay footage gracing
the screens of millions of people around
the world I gave her a haircut [ __ ]
I'll be $10 hey chief who began to
stream for at night full-time in tandem
with much of the streaming world while
the game was rising early in 2018 though
chief whose growth was not tied to the
inherent outrageousness that watching
fortnight can foster what are you
knocking with I missed it you bursted me
that's not gonna pay it's true that when
you're wearing a superhero outfit
smacking down buildings with a
fluorescent unicorn and firing off
rounds of a minigun there's a tendency
for things to get a little Blacky
you do the tap
maybe nothing more exemplifies this that
his on-brand rejection of the in-game
cosmetics fortnight is loved for I do
not give a [ __ ] about any skins or any V
bucks or any [ __ ] in this game that
I don't care T foo is known for his love
of the default skin playing the game as
bare-bones as possible and has even
become synonymous with one of those
defaults in particular the blonde
jonesy skin it is the male character
that looks kind of like me you know a
buff version to me that would be my
number one spot this dad sees [ __ ]
actually insane it looks just like him
he just doesn't give a [ __ ] I'm coming
for you lava but in a way that's what
makes you feel like you're kicking back
and playing fortnight with a friend
you owe it after fortnight's rise on
twitch there was an immediate hunger for
esports competition and it was in that
mold that soft underbelly between
eSports and streaming that T Fuu would
call home from then on his stream was
growing and by May of 2018 he was
averaging around 10,000 viewers at a
time legacy eSports oryx had their eyes
on the game they wanted streamers that
could play on stage as the eSports scene
started to grow and in eSports there's
one org that's managed to monetize that
same swagger the T foo is branding
himself with on stream yeah this gave
him a call I don't know he's doing it in
answer unfortunately a damn phase TV was
born
[Music]
from there T Fuu blew up he was
streaming to an average of 42 thousand
viewers by July 2018 had his fortnight
account banned for a count selling had
his twitch and YouTube hack partnered
with cloak C to form the most lethal duo
in fortnight and became one of the
game's most prolific personalities yeah
I got banned on Twitch been on YouTube
when they're about the baby from
Hollywood fades out and as he grew so
did competitive fortnight he and cloak
waged a coordinated assault on the
game's competitive scene another one
under me got him they're all dead go
baby
pop pop with 8 kills real quick let's go
yeah I think that I think everyone is
here everyone's here let's go baby guy
next to you beam
it's him baby let's go baby
in the early days when the competitive
scene consisted primarily of small
Friday for tonight events t foo won four
of the first five events he competed it
we're talking about time once epic got
the skirmish series off the ground chief
who began his assault on the series he's
gonna take the fall he took some fall
damage t view in game number one Trump
the Royal Flush with eight eliminations
planned on first TV / Liezel rocket
they're fighting it's too long v1
situation here I think they both know T
view is that's one more wall but it was
logic he's gonna storm and hit some with
the og dance the ultimate disrespect
he won $27,000 in week four twenty
thousand in week five forty seven
thousand in his first fall skirmish
series win and another cool thirty seven
thousand right before twitchcon which
was shaping up to be the biggest event
for tonight's short competitive history
ghost Aiden Nick marks point to cloak
see Mitro Majin just the same three
Jill's going in later I mean it's gonna
be really fun and if you didn't know
teef who's name before that event sure
as hell did after I would say without a
doubt if these two take home the victory
if they keep this trend going there at
seventeen islands after only three games
and they were at 20 after four games in
he won if they can win this thing and
keep this going absolutely the best duo
right now in for tonight without it out
oh my gosh they go for a riff to get
here 25 eliminations look at the
material most 20,000 materials use Jack
I think that's more material than if I
I've ever used bow paratis most
Zealand's most eliminations of the
weekend
22
they win $60,000 for that cloaks he had
22 a limbs Depp with a Battlestar this
weekend about absolutely MVP across the
board what an absolute beast I don't
even know what to say like
to be in this position after winning two
solos fall skirmishes like back-to-back
like this is a dream come true like I
get more loss of words T Fu's
independently pocketed just under five
hundred thousand dollars in total
earnings from competitive fortnight
alone in under a year but that's only a
small part of his story because what's
unique about T Fuu is how he's taken his
fans along for that ride true to his
YouTube roots hello youtube I have not
posted in 47 years so I'm gonna post the
video today I'm gonna try to post videos
almost every possibly maybe every day
maybe every month I don't know we'll see
he's a celebrity first and a pro player
second and on April 15th he proved that
this is my last competitive [ __ ] as the
World Cup he may be winning
back-to-back-to-back pro scrims
I got three in a row but I really didn't
get like getting stacked lobbies yeah
but that's content first and practice
second because the Tifa show never stops
you can cut while I play
he lets you write through the door of
the la faze clan cloud house or his
Florida family home the 15-foot paddle
board as a giant fidget spinner some
Brooklyn [ __ ] there was a Brooklyn [ __ ]
he's living the kind of life every kid
was banked the driver and dropped off
the battle bus into frosty flights
dreams of and he's not hiding any of it
he's blogging it streaming it tweeting
it and cramming it it's in your face and
it's cool as hell I just want to rip it
around on the line scooter go ahead dude
the roads open since February 2019 he's
the fastest growing streamer on Twitch
and eclipses 210 million subscribers on
YouTube by many metrics
he's even risen above the likes of ninja
his ninja like was like family-friendly
should mushrooms a bunch of savage
college kids that don't come we just saw
here chillin ninja thinks he's the best
Turner's better than his he's the
five-tool gamer live every day and he
brings you into the room with him
whether he's complaining about the
latest fortnight patch public like
public regular playlist should not have
health for killin not have Matt's per
pill I said that was stupid before they
added it but that [ __ ] does not belong
in public games at all or tattooing his
support a creator code on his YouTube
star friend in front of 50,000 people
[Laughter]
there's a lot made of gaming going
mainstream and eSports getting the
traditional sports treatment but T Foos
making the case for the mouse and
keyboard going Hollywood from spending a
million dollars in a day and buying a
warehouse for fun to hanging
with athletes and being gifted his own
life-size battle bus T foo is becoming a
figure that transcends gaming the first
I ever drove a bus in the battle of
freely yeah through your monitor he
transports you to a world of limitless
cash and jonesy default skin solo
victory
[Music]
absolutely demolished but through it all
he's never lost touch of where he
started in his own backyard with a
crappy camera and some boyish pranks
every night he logs on and he brings you
the same grass roots experience you had
last stream a friend to kick back with
and not take anything too seriously
[Music]
he's quite literally making millions
winning at video games and acting cool
on the internet and it's for that reason
the T Fu's not going anywhere
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]